we're expecting Howard Beck of bleach
report to Colin right now correct
correct
okay is it is it Howard or is it BR one
two three four five six seven eight on
the phone line did it sound like I'm not
sure it might be a but I don't care at
the moment let's go to the phone lines
right now is this a bot or is this
Howard Beck on the phone line here on
the shop I can verify as Howard back
that this is the real Howard back with a
blue checkmark
okay blue checkmarks show up on your
caller ID I don't I don't think so but
can you give yourself a blue checkmark I
know of so many people in the early days
of Twitter we're begging for it but how
are you Howard how do I know it's the
real great question well I've got two
people you know anything anymore
I've got two people looking at me can
you verify this this is me Chris can you
verify this mean you're not where's the
drop on the crazy meter where does this
rank 1 to 10 for you Howard in your
history covering this league absolutely
a at least a 9 9 plus but you know the
craziness of it rich is really about
whether or not this is Bryan Colangelo
responsible for these accounts now he
has said that he is not responsible for
the ones that are in question there was
one that he did cop to it's not unusual
for NBA GM's NBA coaches NBA owners to
have you know what we call burner
accounts are just simply anonymous
accounts to follow and see what
everybody's talking about it doesn't
necessarily work right they're just
there to read and see what people are
saying they're not interacting they're
not engaging and if it's just the one
that Bryan Colangelo said was his in the
ringer story then there's there's
nothing else to this and and that crazy
meter drops from a 9 to maybe 6 because
we still have to wonder ok well then who
did all this and why did the person who
did this leave all these fingerprints
that seems to implicate Bryan Colangelo
was he being set up I mean I know that
sounds like a stretch but look
anything's possible at this point and I
will say this I have been in touch with
somebody close to Bryan Colangelo within
the last hour so who says absolutely
positively was not him and you know I
take that person at their word it's
somebody who's definitely
someone I've known a long time was
credible and you know we'll see where
the sixers investigation goes because if
it's not Bryan Colangelo responsible for
those accounts somebody with inside
information seemingly has been
responsible for either maintaining those
accounts or feeding somebody whoever's
running those accounts so there's still
even if you can determine through just
digital footprints that it's not Bryan
Colangelo you still have to wonder or
figure out who is responsible for that
information getting to those accounts
well if it isn't Colangelo then it's
somebody that knows his history and
where he's been in previous stops along
his career and knows specific people
that he's come across in personal
business in life to place as followers
on these accounts people that these
accounts follow and then this morning I
saw somebody in the media I don't know
off the top of my head unfortunately but
I did see this on Twitter and I'm not
really one of those people who said I
see it online I believe it that they
tried to change the passwords on these
accounts and every single one of the
phone numbers that are associated with
the account that came back check this
phone number for the code all had the
same last two digits so there's a lot of
they're they're powered yeah there's a
ton of there they're on this front right
no it would seem that way rich I
disagree at all all I can tell you is
that somebody close to Bryan has told me
definitively it wasn't him and you know
they're just hoping that the
investigation has the ability with you
know just the digital forensics to be
able to disprove that it was Brian
whether it's somebody else internally or
somebody on his behalf or just somebody
else with information within the sixers
that that would be the question then and
yes there so there's so much that points
to Bryan Colangelo I think if we were in
a in a courtroom you we would call this
all circumstantial evidence yes whether
that's compelling enough I don't know
but I just I'm one who I tend to have a
high bar on these things like I I can't
I don't disagree with you that you look
at all these things I had the same
reaction everybody else did I read it I
go
and this this is really damning this
looks very if not definitive
it certainly is pointing a very strong
synchronous and in one direction and I'm
not dismissing any of that but I have a
high bar in my own mind about okay what
what qualifies us as proof before we
throw a guy's career out the door
Bleacher Report's howard back here on
the Rich Eisen show do you think that if
it is him that it does rise to the level
of termination of career ruining moment
I mean as you know on this day and age
powered when a story comes out you
consume it you think oh my god this is a
horrible story or you think this is a
bizarre story in this case and then you
start wondering like what what what is
the actual fitting penalty for this
crime if there is a crime at all right
so where do you think this lies if it
does come out that all of the accounts
are Bryan Colangelo
Howard yeah if that were the case yes
right I I have to believe that they
probably end up terminating or that he
ends up resigning you know it's a mutual
parting because the embarrassment
brought on the franchise by this entire
saga and also by the information in
those tweets would be tough to overcome
and you need your your general manager
who is you know one of the faces of your
franchise and and one of the most
important ones when it comes to making
trades recruiting free agents dealing
with people all throughout the league
credibility is is key and if it were
proven that it were Bryan Colangelo then
you know you're losing standing if
there's an credibility you're certainly
you know losing with your own players
some of whom if again if it were him you
have besmirched and so that's a problem
I don't see how you survive that if if
they can prove that it was him and and
it's not just any free agency period
that's coming up to Howard right I mean
in all seriousness with the Sixers
announcing that they're looking into
this an independent investigation I mean
I don't know if there's gonna be a
special counsel and if Colangelo needs
to recuse himself if you want to keep on
mirroring real life here in a way the
fact is that there are just four weeks
until the greatest free agent in the
history
free-agency hits the market once again
with a lot of people connecting dots
between LeBron and Philadelphia I mean
this is something they've got to clean
up there's a draft to obviously they've
got to clean this thing up in the next
3-4 weeks don't you think fast I would
say sooner than that yeah I mean I
didn't you're the this needs to take
days not weeks you know I mean a week or
two maybe but look the finals could be
over a week from Friday like if it's a
sweep and that's a very that's
definitely in play the finals could be
over you know nine days from now ten
days so I I think they need to clear
this up as fast as humanly possible and
whether that's whether that's possible
or not you know in terms of what an
investigation takes I got you know we're
all just guessing here I don't know what
how deep you can go on this I don't know
what the you know forensic investigative
capabilities of the Sixers or whoever
they hire to get into digital
fingerprints and try to figure out how
to track this stuff and either prove
that it is as a particular person or
disprove that it's Bryan Colangelo like
I don't I don't know what that requires
but yes they need to get this done fast
there's a lot at stake in this offseason
well you got to figure if there's a
source again as I mentioned the top of
the show if there's a source that the
ringer had that's an artificial
intelligence that coagulated all of
these coordinates you have to figure the
sixers can hire somebody to do the same
thing Howard Becca bleacher report here
before I let you go here into that good
day great story you wrote on the Kerr
draymond green relationship and how it
was born I'd love for you to give you
the floor about the article that
everybody should seek out on bleacher
report right now on on the moment when
that relationship was forged by fire in
a way ya know and then thank you for the
kind words on that rich um yeah so you
know everybody knows about everybody
who's followed the NBA or followed
sports remembers that infamous clash
between draymond Green and Steve Kerr at
halftime of a game in Oklahoma in 2016
where Lisa Salters of ESPN had overheard
some screaming she reports it
immediately turns out it was dream on
green screaming it's the economists
screaming back curtain you know Green at
one point looks as if he's going to go
after
physically and you know this was
certainly the low point of their
relationship and I think everything
that's fun forward from that including a
story by ESPN magazine six months later
was all indicating about or or
suggesting hey look they've got a dream
on green problem how are they going to
solve this problem can they survive
draymond Green if he's a guy who might
break this dynasty up before it even
gets going and you know this is all in
the same season of course that he got
suspended in the finals may lose to
Cleveland that saga that that's that
particular moment in Oklahoma that
stretch of time as it turns out was the
most critical time in what forged a
really deep bond between the two they
are now really close friends draymond
Green told me for that story that occurs
right up there with Tom Izzo and dream
on zone mom in terms of people who truly
get him who he truly trusts we can tell
anything to and he says the Steve Kerr
is his friend for life this is somebody
who will recall any time in the future
about anything going on far from
basketball and it's because they had
that breakthrough with that that moment
where they knew you know basically
wanted to kill each other and could have
pulled this team apart allowed them to
then come back a few days later have a
really great heart-to-heart talk where
they established trust and they broke
through it and ever since then they've
that's just been something they've been
nurturing ever since and these guys they
are as tight as can be and seekers as
through this understood learned how to
manage drayman's obviously very unique
personality drayman's learned how to
reach the occur better they both say
they're better for it it's a really
incredible just evolution of these two
men and I just I was fascinated by it
and of a just privileged that they both
were opening up about it yeah and it was
a great article certainly in light of
what happened in Game one of the series
against the Rockets the Western
Conference final Howard where it took
all of 62 seconds for draymond Green
elbow James Harden in the head and I
thought to myself that's a flashback to
a game 4 of the finals right of that
very year Orton where draymond lost
control of his leg into a place where
King James and we all as men in the
world feel it
that that that kind of diffused the
situation where Kurt Connor brought over
draymond Green and and just kind of like
a whisper conversation with him and
nothing came of it after that yeah yeah
and you could point to a few different
you can point to a few different moments
whether it's in this post season or the
last you know a couple of years where
you know when draymond Green is having
one of those moments where he's you know
a little bit on edge
it's whatever mood he's in that night or
he's just overly amped up and speaker
doesn't you know he doesn't call him out
he doesn't overreact or try to rein him
in he understands that there's a line
that that dreamin has to tow for dream
on to be himself like that intensity is
part of who he is and we see this all
the time in sports you know there was
the let Rodman be Rodman and you know
various individuals over the over time
where to get the best out of them you've
got to let them express themselves in a
certain way and sometimes that means
toeing the line stepping over the line
but the trust that is there now is that
Steve Kerr knows that dream on will
bring himself in before things get to be
damaging before it sinks them and we
haven't seen that happen since that
suspension the finals a couple years ago
so I think it just shows that that
that's you know that's very month
evolution there and that in speaker had
a big role in that
in once the earnest trust then he could
I think help him kind of understand
where the lines are yeah great article
on a again a great read on a very
crucial relationship that makes the
Warriors as great as they are Howard
really appreciate it reached appreciate
the conversation we'll chat during the
finals absolutely rich appreciate it
thanks man you got that soured back of
bleach report at Howard Beck on Twitter
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience